AND BADLY WOUNDED.
>> Tucker: THANKS SO MUCH.
ON LAST NIGHT’S SHOW, WE TOLD
YOU ABOUT THE CASES OF TWO MEN,
JULIAN ASSANGE AND JOHN KERRICK.
JULIAN ASSANGE IS AN
INTERNATIONAL JOURNALIST, JOHN
KERRICK IS A FORMAL CIA OFFICER,
WE’RE NOT TRYING TO SHOW YOU THE
POLITICS OF EITHER MAN BUT BOTH
OF THEIR CASES TELL YOU
SOMETHING REALLY IMPORTANT ABOUT
WHAT’S GOING ON IN THIS COUNTRY
COME ABOUT WHAT MATTERS AND
ABOUT WHAT THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE
WOULD LIKE TO PREVENT YOU FROM
DOING.
JULIAN ASSANGE AND JOHN KERRICK
BOTH WENT TO JAIL FOR TELLING
THE TRUTH, NEITHER ONE STOLE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS FROM THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT, NEITHER ONE OF
THEM HACKED INTO ANYTHING.
JULIAN ASSANGE TOLD YOU A LOT
ABOUT WHAT THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
WAS DOING A BROAD AND TOLD YOU
EVERYTHING ABOUT WHAT THE DNC
WAS DOING TO RIG ITS OWN
PRIMARIES BACK IN 2016 --
REMEMBER THE WIKILEAKS DUMP?
YOU KNOW ABOUT THAT BECAUSE OF
JULIAN ASSANGE.
IF YOU ARE A BERNIE SANDERS
VOTER, YOU ARE PROBABLY GLAD TO
KNOW THAT, EVERYONE ELSE WAS
LYING TO YOU, JULIAN ASSANGE
BROUGHT YOU INFORMATION THAT YOU
HAD A RIGHT TO KNOW.
JOHN KERRICK MEANWHILE TOLD THE
TRUTH ABOUT WHAT OUR MILITARY
AND OUR INTEL AGENCIES WERE
DOING DURING THE IRAQ WAR, YOU
MAY NOT AGREE WITH HIS POSITION
BUT WHAT HE SAID WAS TRUE.
THAT MATTERS ABOVE ALL BECAUSE
TRUTH IS AND MUST BE A DEFENSE.
IF YOU SAID SOMETHING TRUE, YOU
SHOULDN’T BE PUNISHED BECAUSE WE
SHOULD VALUE TRUTH ABOVE ALL.
IN BOTH CASES, THOSE MEN WENT TO
PRISON, AND IN THOSE CASES,
TONIGHT AND ONE OF HIS FINAL
ACTS AS PRESIDENT, DONALD TRUMP
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THAT
RIGHT, TO PARDON BOTH OF THEM.
WE TOLD YOU THAT LAST NIGHT, WE
ARE HEARING TONIGHT THAT NEITHER
MAN, PARTICULARLY
JULIAN ASSANGE -- WE DON’T KNOW
IF THIS IS TRUE IS LIKELY TO GET
A PARDON, WHY?
APPARENTLY BECAUSE REPUBLICANS
IN THE SENATE -- AND BY
REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE WE
MADE MITCH McCONNELL OF
KENTUCKY, THE LEADER OF
REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE HAS
SENT WORD OVER TO THE
WHITE HOUSE -- IF YOU PARDON
JULIAN ASSANGE, WE ARE MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO CONVICT YOU IN AN
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
IS IT LEGAL TO HOLD THAT OVER
THE PRESIDENT’S HEAD?
WE ARE NOT LAWYERS, WE DON’T
KNOW -- IT’S CERTAINLY WRONG.
MORE THAN THAT IT TELLS YOU
EVERYTHING ABOUT THEIR
PRIORITIES.
AT A TIME WHEN THIS COUNTRY IN
SOME WAYS IS COMING APART, WE
ARE AT THE PIVOT POINT IN
AMERICAN HISTORY AND IF YOU ARE
WATCHING THIS SHOW YOU PROBABLY
FEEL THREATENED AND FOR GOOD
REASON, THERE ARE PEOPLE ON THE
OTHER CHANNELS SAYING THEY ARE
GOING TO HUNT YOU DOWN LIKE A
TERRORIST.
AT THAT MOMENT, WHAT IS
MITCH McCONNELL?
YOUR DESIGNATED DEFENDER IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE WORRYING
ABOUT?
HE’S WORRYING ABOUT PROTECTING
THE PARTY IN PERMANENT
WASHINGTON, THEY ARE THE REASON
BOTH THESE MEN HAVE BEEN LOCKED
UP BECAUSE BOTH OF THESE MEN
EMBARRASSED PERMANENT
WASHINGTON, THAT IS THEIR CRIME.
HIS PRIORITY IN THE FINAL HOURS
OF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT THEY REMAIN
PUNISHED FOR DOING THAT.
IT TELLS YOU EVERYTHING.
WE DON’T KNOW WHAT’S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN THE END, WE GOT A
NUMBER OF HOURS LEFT FOR THE